senna
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
nous sommes à bruxelles au parlement
européen et dans cette émission nous
parlons du mariage homosexuel en europe
il est autorisé dans cinq pays européens
dont la belgique où il est totalement
entré dans les moeurs
en france françois hollande s'est engagé
à le légaliser
mais d'abord l'actualité les eurobonds
sont ils le remède miracle à la crise
c'est la question de la semaine
my name is born
nom de code eurobonds emprunts lancés en
commun sur les marchés leur mission
sauver les pays en détresse de
l'eurozone
aujourd'hui tous les états membres
emprunte de l'argent sur les marchés
pour financer leur dette
mais tous ne paye pas le même prix les
taux sont très faibles pour l'allemagne
autour de 1,5 pour cent plus élevés pour
la france 2 8% et astronomiques pour la
grèce avec près de 30% mais avec les
eurobonds tout le monde serait traité de
la même façon car le fardeau de la dette
serait assumée en commun par les 17 pays
de la zone euro qui serait donc tous
soumis aux mêmes taux d'intérêt les
eurobonds agirait donc comme un bouclier
contre les attaques des marchés qui ne
pourraient plus spéculer contre les
états les plus fragiles de la zone
mais l'idée divise les européens et en
premier lieu le couple franco allemand
elle est défendue par le président
français françois hollande qui plaide
pour un renforcement de la solidarité
financière européenne n'est berlin ne
veut pas des euro bonds pour la
chancelière allemande c'est la porte
ouverte à la feignantise budgétaire des
états les plus endettés
et pas question de payer pour les
mauvais élèves grecs martel l'allemagne
alors en ces temps de crise de la dette
les eurobonds sont ils la solution
miracle ou juste une illusion
pour réagir à l'actualité nous sommes
cette semaine avec robert rochefort
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen depuis plus de trois ans ici au
parlement européen où cigéo groupe des
démocrates et des libéraux pour l'europe
et vous êtes économiste est ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre les eurobonds je
suis absolument pour néanmoins il faut
bien comprendre que les eurobonds death
est pas une solution miracle c'est à
dire que ça ça n'évite pas le fait de
devoir faire les réformes de structure
qu'il faut faire dans les pays européens
mais cette évidemment quelque chose de
fondamental surtout dans la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes
pour faire simple les oraux bronze c'est
si on veut regarder ce qui se passe aux
etats unis c'est le fait qu'aux états
unis la californie serait en défilant en
déficit est en faillite complet s'il n'y
avait pas une sorte d'emprunts
américains unique sans l'ensemble des
états unis d'amérique
et bien c'est faire la même chose en
europe alors que nous n'avons pas encore
les états unis d'europe
oui alors est-ce que c'est comparable
justement ce états unis c'est un système
fédéral en france pour la cei a pas de
convergence
alors c'est ce que disent les allemands
en particulier les allemands disent
avant de de pouvoir faire des euro bond
il faut faire une démarche de type
fédéral affirmé et avancer vers ces
états unis d'europe démarche qui n'est
possible pour les allemands que si nous
avons d'abord fait nos réformes
chez nous pays par pays et donc
finalement il ya cette espèce de deux
d'idées de savoir si c'est la poule
d'abord où l'oeuf d'abord les rigoristes
pourrait-on dire dit
faites d'abord vous réformes de
structure éliminez vos déficits
excessifs et après nous pourrons faire
une mutualisation de nos dépenses
et puis les pays qui sont favorables aux
aubes 11 10 il faut rentrer dans cette
logique de rigueur mais il faut pas
attendre d'avoir déjà complètement fêlé
rigueur pour faire cette mutualisation
de la dette parce que si on le fait dès
maintenant on retrouve une bouffée
d'oxygène oxygène on met fin à la
spéculation contre les marchés aux
bestiaux wincc absolument ma position
alors après on fait de la politique
donc la question qui se pose c'est
comment on avance quand il y a deux
positions pratiquement irréconciliables
pour faire simple en allemagne la gauche
allemande le spd est également contre
les eurobonds donc en fait c'est
l'allemagne qui est contre les zoos
bronze
il faut dire au passage qu'elle en
profite parce que vous savez c'est des
vases communicants c'est à dire quand
prêter à la grèce moi l'espagne ou à
l'italie coûte extrêmement cher
c'est avec les taux d'intérêt sont très
élevées c'est parce que les prêteurs ont
peur qu'il y ait un défaut
en revanche comme il faut tout de même
qui place l'argent quelque part
l'allemagne qui leur apparaît comme un
paradis sans aucun risque qui sont
prêtes à demander un taux d'intérêt
extrêmement bas donc le taux d'intérêt
en allemagne est d'autant plus bas d'une
certaine façon il est d'autant plus
élevé ailleurs
mais quel intérêt l'allemagne et or est
d'accepter ces eurobonds qui conduirait
quand même à augmenter le taux en tout
cas à l'aller
alors l'intérêt de l'allemagne à
accepter cela c'est tout simplement de
faire vivre la zone euro c'est-à-dire de
faire en sorte que ça puisse continuer
et que l'allemagne qui est bénéficiaire
du marché unique européen et qui
exportent beaucoup y compris dans les
pays de l'union se trouve avec des
marchés qui soient des marchés à peu
près stabilisés et non pas avec quelque
chose qui risque de retomber malgré tout
sur l'allemagne
c'est le risque de défaut de sortie de
l'euro de la grèce si la grèce sort de
la zone euro c'est une catastrophe pour
les époux pour les grecs mais c'est
aussi une catastrophe pour les allemands
si l'espagne ne peut plus payer ses
dettes
c'est aussi une catastrophe est
peut-être en train de se produire au
site women va mal alors alors simplement
on est en train de faire en europe
quelque chose qui est que comme on ne
veut pas que l'allemagne
on ne veut pas que l'espagne s'écroulent
comme on ne voulait pas que la grèce
s'écroule
eh bien on finit par trouver des
solutions temporaires qui coûte
extrêmement cher
donc là il ya un débat aujourd'hui sur
l'espagne parce que l'espagne 10 comme
d'ailleurs l'ont dit avant la l'irlande
le portugal 10 on va s'en tirer tout
seul on n'a pas vraiment besoin du
soutien financier de l'europe
on sait très bien que c'est pas le cas
on sait très bien que l'espagne va
devoir être aidés est en réalité la
question c'est de savoir si on peut
continuer à aider les pays qui sont au
bord du gouffre en leur donnant une
petite comment dire un petit secours au
moment où ils sont au bord du gouffre
pour ne pas tomber dans le gouffre mais
se retrouve en deux semaines ou trois
mois plus tard de nouveau à la limite du
goût fait mais on peut pas aider ces
pays n'ont plus à fond perdu
est ce que en échange il faut exiger des
réformes structurelles il faut explique
aussi à la france il faut les deux alors
été confiées à la fois s'applique
évidemment la france
simplement il se trouve qu'actuellement
la france mais ça c'est un effet de
calendrier
françois hollande en bénéficient tant
mieux pour lui parce que la france en
bénéficier avec lui mais il se trouve
que nous sommes encore pour quelques
semaines ou quelques mois on ne sait pas
très bien du bon côté c'est à dire que
comme c'est d'ailleurs été rappelés dans
votre sujet il ya quelques instants
les taux d'intérêts donnée à la dette
souveraine dans la saison relativement
faible mais je voudrais vous dire
simplement
puisqu'on parle ici de l'actualité
européenne il ya malgré tout un petit
espoir qui est survenu et quelques jours
c'est vous savez alors je vais essayer
d'expliquer simplement vous savez que
dans les critères de convergence
normalement il ne faut pas que la dette
souveraine dépasse 60% du pib des pays
bas en réalité cette dette pour beaucoup
de pays est au-dessus de 60% alors les
oraux bomb
il ya eu plusieurs formules proposées la
première formule c'était de dire on va
mutualiser la dette qui est en tout 60 %
du pib
et puis ça c'est ça qui ne marche pas
bien ayez propositions actuellement
complètement inverse qui semble avancer
qui peut être intéressante qui est de
dire on va mutualiser la dette qui est
au-dessus des 60% du pib
avec ce qu'on appelle la création d'un
fonds de rédemption et même si c'est pas
ma préférence si on arrive à mettre le
doigt dans l'engrenage d'un peu de
mutualisation de la dette serait bien je
crois qu'on va dans la bonne direction
alors les allemands évidemment pour
sauver l'honneur dire on se sera jamais
d euros bronze en pratique ce sera quand
même un peu déçu en tout cas le débat
est lancé
merci beaucoup à robert rochon ans
d'avoir été avec nous on parle de la
grèce et notamment des propos de
christine lagarde directrice générale du
fmi qui a rendu un avis sévère sur la
grèce cela a fait la une des télévisions
d'europe regarder
la directrice générale du fonds
monétaire international est interrogé
par un journaliste d'un quotidien
britannique
à la question relative aux difficultés
rencontrées par les grecs
christine lagarde selon dans une
comparaison jugée maladroite
je pense plus à ses enfants dans un
village du niger qui vont deux heures
par jour à l'école partageant une chaise
pour 3 et qui rêve d'avoir une bonne
éducation
j'estime qu'ils ont encore plus besoin
dead que les gens athènes de nombreux
grecs sont remontés et choqué par de
tels propos c'est deux à trois mille
personnes qui se sont suicidées quelle
faute ont-ils commis se demande cet
homme au début j'avais une retraite 2007
180 euros maintenant je gagne 1200 vins
dit ce retraité
que dois je dire à mon fils qui est
handicapée que je suis le cobaye des
expériences de madame lagarde
j'avais vécu à la plage
la grèce est à un point de non retour
l'union européenne souhaite que le pays
reste dans la zone euro laisse en plan
daide concret la grèce qui est assommée
par la crise les coupes budgétaires et
les spéculateurs pense déjà à revenir à
la drachme
ce qui serait un moindre mal ainsi la
ferraille d'aujourd'hui pourra devenir
de la monnaie de demain les prévisions
pour la grèce sont très sombres
le pays va devoir choisir ou sera forcé
d'abandonner l'euro et de revenir à la
drachme
si un tel scénario se produit personne
ne peut dire quelles en seront les
conséquences mais cela sera en tout cas
un désastre le pays fera faillite le
chômage explose rares l'appelation aussi
puisque la banque centrale devra faire
marcher la planche à billets pour
renflouer le système bancaire se perdre
au parking nous sommes avec vangelis
demiri ce bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste franco grecque correspondant
ici à bruxelles pour la télévision
grecque est une agence de presse aussi
et vous publiez la face cachée de la
crise grecque très prochainement aux
éditions de la boîte de pandore ça ne
s'invente pas alors votre regard sur ce
qui se passe est d'abord comment avez
vous accueilli les propos de christine
lagarde sur votre pays n'y a pas de
doute que ces propos étaient humiliant
etc sans maladroit déplacer violent et
tout d'abord injuste pour le pays pour
tout un peuple pour le 80 % des salariés
des retraités grecs qui sont imposés à
la source et qui payent leurs impôts
normalement quand on dit que les grecs
ne paye
échappent à l'impôt ne payent pas
d'impôts c'est en partie faux les
responsabilités de la grèce en tant que
fraude fiscale sont indéniables bien sûr
qu'il ya la faute risque à la grèce bien
sûr que c'est un sport national c'est
une première le reconnaître à partir de
l'un critiquer tout un peuple c'est
vraiment injuste
donc à partir de là il faut remettre en
place certaines choses il faut qu' il
faut aider les grecs pour combattre ce
fléau
c'est vraiment un fléau en grèce il ya
pas de doute et bien sûr il ya aussi des
grandes responsabilités de la part des
armateurs aussi de l'église orthodoxe
qui ne contribue pas à l'effort national
alors quelle est cette face cachée de la
de la crise grecque
et surtout quel est pour vous le vrai
talon d'achille du pays
est ce que c'est un problème avant tout
économique ou alors politique puisque on
accuse la grèce on reproche à grèzes
n'avoir jamais su construire un état
digne de ce nom
le problème se pose sur plusieurs
niveaux je pense aux niveaux politique
économique mais avant tout sociale
derniers mois les deux dernières des
deux dernières années pendant cette
crise grecque
donc à partir de là ma conviction
personnelle c'est qu'il ya une
complicité entre la grèce et l'union
européenne il ya un grand malentendu
dans ses 31 ans de partition une
participation de la grèce dans l'union
européenne est de 11 ans dans la
participation en ce qui concerne l'euro
à partir de là il ya une question de
solidarité que se posent les européens
doivent aider la grèce on est tous une
famille européenne
la grèce doit faire ses tâches doit
remplir ses tâches doit mettre de
l'ordre dans sa maison il n'ya pas de
doute il faut qu'on continue avec les
réformes structurelles et bien sûr je
mange eu très très très inquiet très
perplexe avec ce qui se passe en grèce
en ce moment l'ambiance politique dans
laquelle la campagne électorale se
déroule vous faites allusion à l'entrée
de c2c parti ouvertement xénophobe et
les élections de 17 juin est ce que vous
pensez que la démocratie est menacée en
grèce la démocratie n'est pas menacer
les fondements les racines de la
démocratie sont très très bien sous
démocratie est bien là n'est pas le
problème
il ya un grand problème un grand risque
d'explosion sociale les gens sont
désespérés sont colère sont indignés ils
se sont piétinés par la cure injuste et
inappropriée qui est infligé par l'union
européenne par l'eurozone en général
à partir de là il faut voir un peu ce
qu'on va se payer ce qui va se passer
dans ces élections
malheureusement tous les jours on
assiste à des menaces à des chantages
dirigeants européens de dirigeants
internationaux qui ne faut quoi ils ne
font que renforcer les mouvements
extrêmes
c'est un gauche extrême droite et ça
c'est très inquiétant comme comme
message pour le peuple grec les peuples
grecs dans l'élection du 6 mai ont
déclaré à haute voix qu'ils veulent le
soutien ils veulent participer dans
l'euro à 89 81 % les grecs veulent
participer dans l'euro cessé leurs
propres envies de sang s'est pas remis
en question
à partir de là il faut revoir cette cure
inappropriés qu'il faut aller plus
doucement dans le rythme des réformes
que c'est trop trop brutale en si peu de
temps de redresser un et en si peu de
temps il faut il faut ralentir le rythme
il est indéniable qu'on peut pas revoir
dans sa totalité le programme qui était
décidée en février qui a été signé par
tous les pays membres la grèce inclus le
gouvernement grec a signé il doit
respecter sa signature ces engagements
ça c'est indéniable à partir de là le 17
juin il faut un gouvernement stable
viable qui puisse mener à plein ses
engagements envers l'union européenne
les réformes structurelles bien sûr et à
partir de là il faut aussi que l'europe
revoit un peu cette dose donc essayer de
soulager un peu c'est ce programme qui
était décédé en février
eh bien merci beaucoup vangelis des
maristes avoir été avec nous et on se
reverra sans doute très prochainement
place à notre partie magazine une
question de société
en belgique le mariage entre deux
personnes de même sexe est autorisée est
même entré dans les moeurs chaque année
1000 mariages sont célébrés reportage à
bruxelles et à braine l'alleud signé
françois beaudonnet et bertrand catrice
comme tous les couples qui entrent dans
cette salle des mariages claude et
andrée sont bien sûr un peu anxieux dans
quelques instants
ils seront unis au nom de la loi a
déclaré vous prendre pour époux monsieur
andré riche et oui déclare unis par les
liens du mariage telle citation
la cérémonie est identique à celle d'un
mariage entre un homme et une femme
car en belgique passer la bague au doigt
d'un conjoints du même sexe n'est pas
chaud qu'au mot ni tout à fait
traditionnelle qui se passe exactement
pareil pour les hétéros justement c'est
ça qui est bien on est content ce soit
pas différent
laurence et alexia elles se sont mariés
il ya trois ans une cérémonie grandiose
à la mairie de bruxelles sur la
prestigieuse grand place un moment de
bonheur qu'alexia de nationalité
française pensait ne jamais pouvoir
partager avec ses parents sachant que
j'étais lesbienne et que je vivais en
france avant je pense que quelque part
ils ont fait un peu ce deuil laddh
j'assisterai peut-être pas au mariage de
ma fille et que là je pense que ça les a
vachement surpris et pour nos mamans je
crois que dans leur tête ça fait elle se
marie ça y est elle veut faire un bébé
un bébé voit 6 h à 14 mois
c'est laurence qui l'a mise au monde
après une insémination artificielle
en belgique alexia a pu officiellement
l'adopter la petite a donc légalement de
maman voulait qu'on se marre et c'est
que du coup l'enfant qui serait issue de
secours serait l'enfant du couple et pas
l'enfant de l'une ou de l'autre une
enfant sans papa bien sûr plus tard elle
ne manquera pas de poser des questions
mais ces deux mamans veille à ce que
sacha est aussi des présence masculine
elle voit des hommes souvent au niveau 2
des couples qui nous entoure on est une
majorité de couples hétérosexuels aussi
bien choisi son parent parce que
laurence et alexia vivent dans une
petite ville de province
les mariages entre homosexuels ils sont
moins fréquents qu'à bruxelles
et pourtant ici aussi leur couple est
acceptée par tous ça me dérange pas du
tout obligé je les connaisse avec
quelques temps qu'elles viennent elles
sont très gentils noms pour moi c'est le
principal et quand elles partent en
vacances en france dans la rue est lost
à peine marcher main dans la main chez
elle au contraire à braine l'alleud
elles affichent leur union comme
n'importe quel couple toutes les
démarches qu'on a dû faire chez le
gynéco on a accouché ici à
braine-l'alleud tout ça on a fait tous
ensemble mais c'est surtout qu'il y à il
ya aucun doute fallu dire quand tu vois
deux femmes questionne la main et canne
et une qu'un bis des normes ou quétaine
poussette pense que les gens nous disent
pas si on dirait des surfers dans le
royaume où existent pourtant
l'équivalent de notre pacs
plus d'un millier de mariages
homosexuels sont célébrés chaque année
et plus personne ne s'y oppose
voilà donc pour ce reportage que nous
avons réalisés ici en belgique avec
bertrand catrice alors nous avons été
rejoints sur ce plateau par elisabeth
morin-chartier bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne française vous êtes du groupe
ppe donc c'est à dire l'ump en france
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe en
belgique où on sait que le mariage
homosexuel et je dirais entré dans les
moeurs maintenant quelle est votre
première réaction
la première réaction est de dire que un
mariage comme une famille c'est de
l'amour et que au nom de l'égalité des
citoyens
tout le monde a le droit de partager
l'amour en fait une position qui est
personnel j'imagine était pas du tout
celle de votre famille politique
vous savez les étiquettes ça me gratte
donc j'aime pas tellement ça et moi je
réfléchis par moi même
et en tant qu'historienne en plus j'ai
cette vision de l'évolution de la
société dans l'histoire mais l'histoire
de ma propre vie fait que je vois bien
autour de moi les évolutions qui se
passe aujourd'hui est un politique ne
doit pas être ni à courir après les
évolutions mais ni à les bloquer mais
beaucoup plus à comprendre ce qui se
passe dans la société mais on sort d'une
campagne électorale présidentielle en
france et nicolas sarkozy était
clairement opposé est clairement opposé
au mariage au mariage homosexuel
nicolas sarkozy était opposé au mariage
homosexuel
moi je pense que
nous avons un grand or aujourd'hui c'est
d'imaginer que la famille et repose sur
des bases qui sont scientifiques ou qui
sont normés les tests adn comme
composante fondamentale de la famille
nous montre une erreur fondamentale
c'est que une famille sans amour
n'existe pas une famille sans amour ne
fonctionne pas des enfants sans des
parents qui s'aiment ça ne marche pas il
les enfants sont marqués et souffrent
aussi d'érable une famille avec amour
c'est c'est ça que les enfants soient
biologiquement les enfants des parents
qui s'aiment
ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance c'est
l'amour qui fait la famille on voit dans
ce reportage par exemple que la petite
fille sasha à deux mamans est-ce que
même si on voit que c'est de ces deux
mamans sem je crois que ça se voit
est-ce que malgré tout dans le corps
social est ce que ça ne va pas poser un
problème quand elle sera un peu plus
grande le reportage montre très bien
qu'il faut des équilibres en femme ou le
voit on voit dans la société on y voit
en politique on le voit dans
l'entreprise on voit dans
l'administration les équipes mixtes
fonctionne beaucoup mieux que des
équipes monolithique
donc je pense que cet équilibre hommes
femmes dont l'entourage est nécessaire
d'ailleurs on dit très bien dans le
reportage on a choisi avec attention le
parrain pour apporter cette cet
équilibre ça c'est un point qui peut
donc se corriger
avec de la tension ce qui est beaucoup
plus difficile à corriger c'est le
regard des autres c'est à l'heure des
mamans et des papas
à voir tous les jours les deux mamans
qui viennent c'est le regard des autres
parents et le regard des enfants qui va
être plus compliqué à faire évoluer et
tout ça il faut se rendre compte que
c'est certainement de la souffrance et
qu'il y à une évolution à accompagner 12
seulement alors on va regarder quelques
instants une déclaration de françois
hollande alors qu'il n'était pas
président de la république il était
encore candidat et c'était justement
dans un de ses clips de campagne et
regardez ce qu'il disait il y a quelques
semaines j'ai pris un engagement
d'ailleurs c'est celui du parti
socialiste et il faudra le tenir
lorsque nous serons aux responsabilités
de la france c'est le droit au mariage
pour tous les couples sans qu'ils soient
distinguées entre les hétérosexuels ou
les homosexuels c'est un droit qui doit
être reconnue c'est une liberté qui doit
être proposée ça permettra de faciliter
la vie
c'est l'objet même du texte que nous
aurons à faire voter ensuite se posera
la question de l'adoption qui est
aujourd'hui finalement conçues sur le
mode de l'hypocrisie personne seule peut
adopter un couple ne le pourrait pas ce
qui doit être considéré c'est le droit
de l'enfant à être heureux dans une
famille c'est le seul critère qui doit
être regardé donc nous aurons aussi à
modifier les règles permettant un coq
d'accueillir un enfant dans les
conditions qui devront être précisées
donc elisabeth morin-chartier vous êtes
ici donc du groupe ppe je le disais vous
êtes donc de l'ump en france
finalement ce qu'on vient d'entendre de
françois hollande ça pourrait être dans
votre bouche oui à tout à fait je pense
que aujourd'hui il faut faire
extrêmement attention quand on s'engage
sur le mariage homosexuel
on dit pas et après viendra le problème
de l'adoption si en même temps en
politique il faut voir globalement avec
hauteur et distinctions et donc
donc je trouve qu'il commet une faute
considérable de landisacq fut l'un et
l'autre il faut savoir quels sont les
problèmes qui se posent quand on ouvre
une voix comme celle du mariage
homosexuel
il faut savoir que directement après il
y a le en même temps il ya le problème
de de la jeune compagne à la nuance ça
veut dire quoi ça cela signifie que vous
voyez bien que le problème des droits à
l'homosexualité pose le problème de la
pérennité du couple et de la pérennité
de la stabilité de
l'enfant adoptée par l'un ou l'autre
françois hollande dit l'un d'eux adopté
seul moi je les galiciens
il dit aujourd'hui on verra après parce
que dia sont hélas peut adopter celle
dont il dit aujourd'hui à l'hypocrisie
parce que justement comme un couple
homosexuel ne pas adopter c'est un
célibataire qui a deux c'est ça mais
c'est la règle c'est de fait et moi je
dis ne reste ne soyons pas dans cette
hypocrisie là parce que déjà nous voyons
dans les couples hétérosexuels
voyez je dis pas normaux ce que le mot
normal
qu'est ce que c'est je vois bien que
dans les couples hétérosexuels
quand le couple se détricote il y a de
la spoliation
très souvent c'est le père qui est
spolié affectivement parce que dans la
plupart des cas l'enfant est gardé par
l'ama a la garde principale et moi en
tant que vice-présidente à l'égalité des
citoyens dans ce parlement
je me bats contre les inégalités
sociales y compris contre les égalités
inégalités fait opèrent dans des couples
hétéros c'est alors on voit bien que
vous n'avez pas du tout la position qui
est quand même la position de la droite
française et ça m'amène sur la dernière
question avec les sites mais c'est vrai
que la droite française
moi j'ai un côté alain juppé j'ai écouté
des gens comme roselyne bachelot s'est
quand même des gens qui iront à toi
politique et qui ont une nuance et un
engagement sur ce sujet qui les zones en
tout cas c'est un sujet clivant et voilà
dix ans comme ça question justement sur
ici ce sera vraiment ma dernière
question au parlement européen
ce clivage là dessus sur ce sujet du
mariage homosexuel
il n'existe pas de la même façon je
crois entre la entre la gauche et la
droite
non parce que
ici nous avons 27 culture qui
s'entrecroisent 27 histoire différente
et on voit bien que on ne peut pas
cliver droite gauche mais c'est beaucoup
plus des histoires nationales qui
conduisent à des positions ou à des
évolutions c'est très bien c'est ça le
rend comme toujours ici d'ailleurs au
parlement européen c'est beaucoup plus
nuancée que l'on court merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation c'est
la fin de cette émission se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec kathia gilder
d'ici là bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires